27 años de una de las mayores
atrocidades en la historia de la
humanidad este miércoles francia
conmemora el genocidio de ruanda que
dejó entre abril y julio de 1994 más de
800 mil tutsis y hutus moderados
masacrados coincidiendo con el
aniversario francia ha hecho de dominio
público cerca de 8000 documentos
oficiales sobre el papel del estado
francés entre 1900 y 1994 en ruanda
antes en marzo una comisión de
historiadores publicó un informe
encargado por macrón para esclarecer lo
sucedido
aunque francés no es cómplice el acto
criminal del genocidio su acción
contribuyó a que éste sucediera y al no
saberlo ni entenderlo esto es una gran
responsabilidad intelectual es así y no
responsabilidad dirigieron en guisos y
ruanda el presidente paul kagamé también
conmemora el aniversario del genocidio y
kagamé un rebelde la minoría tutsi ha
gobernado el país desde el año 2000 con
la llegada de macrón y su política de
revisión histórica han mejorado las muy
tensas relaciones entre países
activistas ruandeses no se conforman de
muchos gestos había importantes
declaraciones en el informe de uclés
pero termina con el rechazo de la
complicidad de francia aunque todos
somos muy conscientes de lo que sucedió
francia estado contra los tutsis antes
durante y después del genocidio así que
lo que esperamos es una fuerte clara y
verdadera disculpa del presidente
francés y en este sentido se cree que
hay más de 100 perpetuadores del
genocidio en francia sin embargo sólo
han sido condenadas tres personas y se
espera que otras cuatro vayan a juicio